und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend
Geschichte wiederholt sich den Eindruck
kann man haben wenn man auf den Krieg in
der Ukraine schaut hier aktuelle Bilder
von der schwer umkämpften Front bei
bachmut in der Ostukraine
apokalyptisch solche Fotos kennt man
schon von den Feldschlachten des Ersten
Weltkriegs als Schauermann in ein
Geschichtsbuch
an die Vergangenheit wurde heute auch in
Kiew verändert an den holodomore die
Hungersnot von 90 Jahren die der
sowjetische Diktator Stalin auf dem
Gewissen hat falls er ein Gewissen
gehabt hätte in Gedenken daran schickte
auch Bundeskanzler Scholz seine
Videobotschaft er sagte Hunger dürfen
nie wieder als Waffe eingesetzt werden
Ralf panicek berichtet
gedenken am Abend in Kiew die Erinnerung
ist lebendiger denn je die Erinnerung an
das systematische verhungern in der
Ukraine unter stalinistischer Herrschaft
genannt hollodument
mehr als 4 Millionen Menschen starben im
Winter
1932/33 die Folge einer brutalen Politik
der Sowjetunion die die Landwirtschaft
kollektivierte die Bauern auspreste
keine sowjet-republik traf die
Hungerkatastrophe damals so hart wie die
Ukraine forderte so viele Opfer
Präsident selensky vergleicht an diesem
Gedenktag die Vergangenheit mit dem
jetzt Entschuldigung heute ehrt die
Ukraine das Gedenken an Millionen
Millionen von Ukrainern Millionen von
Opfern des hollods die Völker
vernichtende Politik des Kremls damals
wie heute zielt auf die totale Eroberung
des Landes und die Vernichtung des
ukrainischen Volkes
der Ukraine auch heute wurde die Stadt
von russischen Raketen getroffen noch
immer Rauchen die Trümmer dort wo sie am
Morgen einschlugen zum Glück gab es hier
heute nur verletzte keine Toten die
Menschen aber haben alles verloren leben
in ständiger Angst
ebenso in Person im Süden des Landes die
Stadt die gerade erst zurückerobert
wurde doch weiterhin nicht in Sicherheit
ist wieder Bomben wieder Zerstörung
wieder Tod allein 15 Menschen sollen
durch die gestrigen russischen Angriffe
getötet worden sein so die Behörden die
Stadt konnte zwar nach offiziellen
Angaben wieder in das Stromnetz
angeschlossen werden dennoch fehlt es
weiter an allem was ein Überleben
sichert Wärme Zelte der Regierung können
nur etwas helfen
können sich die Menschen zumindest
aufwärmen und ihre Mobilfunkgeräte
aufladen und im Internet surfen gegen
die Kälte gibt es Tee und Kaffee
russische Raketen der kommende Winter
die fehlende Hoffnung viele wollen
nachher schon verlassen und folgen damit
einem Aufruf der Regierung hunderte
lassen sich dafür registrieren andere
haben sich bereits auf den Weg gemacht
kleiner Tat in der Ukraine lässt sich
sehen was es heißt keinen Strom und
keine Heizung mehr zu haben und das
nicht nur mal stundenweise sondern über
Tage alltägliche
Selbstverständlichkeiten gehen nicht
mehr Handy aufladen Waschmaschine
anwerfen Kaffee kochen das Schlafzimmer
eiskalt im Gefrierschrank hingegen tauen
die Lebensmittel auf und wenn durch den
Stromausfall Pumpen ausfallen gibt es
auch kein fließend Wasser mehr auch
nicht auf der Toilette
es sind diese für Millionen Ukrainer
Realität gewordenen schrecken die die
europäischen Regierungen hektisch nach
neuen Energiequellen suchen lassen und
dafür ist man offenkundig auch bereit
Umweltschutz Aspekte zurückzustellen ob
das wirklich sinnvoll ist darüber wird
erbittert gestritten Beispiel Watten wir
und fröller und Britta Behrendt
berichten
eine idyllische Landschaft das
Wattenmeer berühmt für seine Natur und
Tierwelt
sie sind gekommen um dies zu verteidigen
vor dem gashunger Europas denn die
Niederlande suchen nach neuen
Energiequellen Shell will im Watt mehr
ab 2024 nach Gas bohren
wollen wird die Energiekrise nicht lösen
denn es steht es in drei Jahren zur
Verfügung
das Gasfeld liegt unter Wasser 5
Milliarden Kubikmeter will Shell
jährlich aus dem Wattenmeer Punkten
diese Menge ist etwa der Gasverbrauch
Deutschlands in sechs Wochen das auch
Gas erhalten soll die niederländische
Regierung verteidigt das Projekt wir
brauchen die Gasfelder unter dem Watt wo
unsere Energieversorgung und die für
Europa sicher zu stellen
wenige Kilometer entfernt liegt die
Provinz Groningen dort lässt der
niederländische Staat schon seit
Jahrzehnten Gas aus dem gesteinsboden
fördern Erdbeben erschüttern immer
wieder die Region kaum ein Haus ohne
Schäden viele Dörfer gleichen Baustellen
jedes Haus hat ein Problem manche werden
repariert manche abgerissen manche
wieder komplett aufgebaut
in Herbart seit die Energiepreise
steigend diskutieren Sie den Dörfern
wieder mehr Gas zu fördern auch wenn
alle unter den Folgen leiden die
Menschen geraten in Panik wenn es an ihr
Portemonnaie geht
die Angst vor den hohen Kosten und um
die Umwelt in Groningen diskutieren sie
wie überall über den Preis des Gases
und jetzt erstmal Heinz Wolf mit anderen
Nachrichten
Bundeskanzler Scholz hat sich für eine
Reform des Staatsbürgerschaftsrechts
ausgesprochen deutschland brauche
bessere Regelungen für die Einbürgerung
so Scholz gestern waren Reformvorschläge
von Innenministerin Felser dazu bekannt
geworden die türkische Gemeinde in
Deutschland begrüßte die Pläne dagegen
sprach CSU landesgruppenchef Dobrindt in
der Bild-Zeitung von einem verramschen
der deutschen Staatsbürgerschaft
die Reform des Wohngeldes kann nach dem
gestrigen Beschluss des Bundesrates zwar
zum neuen Jahr in Kraft treten aber aus
Sicht von Kommunen und Ländern wird sich
die Umsetzung um Monate verzögern grund
sei unter anderem fehlendes Personal
durch die ihre Form sollen zu den bisher
600.000 Anspruchsberechtigten Haushalten
bundesweit mehrere hunderttausend
hinzukommen
auf der süditalienischen Insel Ischia
ist es nach starken Regenfällen zu
mehreren Erdrutschen gekommen mindestens
ein Mensch kam ums Leben und mehrere
Menschen werden noch vermisst am Morgen
hat es sich eine Lawine aus Schlamm und
Geröll gelöst einige Gebäude wurden
zerstört Straßen wurden und passierbar
zeitweilig waren Teile der Insel ohne
Strom die Schlammmassen begruben Häuser
unter sich und schoben Fahrzeuge ins
Meer
der Mensch will wieder zu Mond als
Vorhut gewissermaßen umkreist in der
Zeit die unbemannte Raumkapsel Orion vor
zehn Tagen in Florida gestartet bewegt
sie sich seit heute auf der Mond
Umlaufbahn und in wenigen Jahren sollen
dann auch wieder Astronauten auf dem
Mond landen geplant ist sogar der Aufbau
einer festen Mondstation und das ist
erst der Anfang
starten und Unternehmen stehen längst in
den Startlöchern um den Mond dauerhaft
zu besiedeln und zu bewirtschaften sich
das vorzustellen mag manchen
schwerfallen aber als vor 53 Jahren der
erste Mensch den Mond betrat hat sich ja
auch niemand vorstellen können dass es
mal so etwas wie privaten
Weltraumtourismus geben würde über
dieses exklusive Reiseerlebnis berichtet
Susanne Freitag
[Musik]
ein paar Minuten schwerelos mit Blue
Origin das Unternehmen von Amazon
Gründer Jeff Bezos macht space
touristenträume wahr an diesem Tag mit
an Bord Sarah Sabri ein
raumfahrtforscherin aus Ägypten und
Spaceman Steve so nennt er sich jetzt
ein Millionär aus Melbourne in Florida
ihr gemeinsames Weltraumabenteuer hat
sie zu Freunden gemacht
es ist schwer zu beschreiben ich benutze
heute vielleicht dieselben Worte wie vor
dem Flug tue dieselben Dinge aber alles
fühlt sich anders an
ich sah mich so wie die anderen auch
der reiche Typ der sich einfach ein
Ticket kaufen kann und ins All fliegt
aber ich sehe heute tatsächlich viele
Dinge anders
wie viel Steve young für seinen Flug
bezahlt hat verrät er nicht Sarah Subway
wurde von einer Organisation gefördert
die ihren Flug finanzierte Ägypten hat
keine Raumfahrtprogramm für
ForscherInnen wie sie der Privatflug
eine Chance
vielleicht ändert das etwas in Ägypten
dass Menschen sich sagen schau es ist
möglich ins All zu fliegen ich komme aus
demselben Dorfer in derselben Schule es
ist vielleicht auch für mich möglich
die Preise für einen Trip ins All legt
blue Origin individuell fest sie
variieren von 0 Dollar bis zu
zweistelligen Millionenbeträgen je nach
Fluggast längst liefern sich die Tech
Giganten blue Origin von Jeff Bezos und
SpaceX von Elon Musk einen erbitterten
Konkurrenzkampf um die besten Plätze im
All die US Weltraumbehörde NASA hat
damit einerseits Konkurrenz verdient
aber auch weil sie Startrampen und
Flächen vermietet und vom Know-how
profitiert es ist Landwirtschaft hilft
der NASA ihre Ziele zu erreichen die
NASA kümmert sich um die Forschung und
die großen Raketen aber je mehr sie an
Logistik an den Privatsektor abgibt
desto effizienter und schneller ist sie
und sie spart viel Geld
die Diskussionen über Nachhaltigkeit und
den Sinn touristischer Missionen im All
laufen die Geschäfte aber laufen auch
das Space Business ist attraktiv für
Anbieter und Kunden
wir brauchen gar nichts mehr sagen wir
verstehen uns einfach blind ohne Worte
weil wir das gemeinsam erlebt haben
dieses Team ist jetzt für immer
miteinander verbunden
wenn Sie Ihr Video ansehen fließen immer
wieder Tränen der Kurztrip ins All hat
ihr Leben verändert und zeigt
gleichzeitig einen Umbruch in der
Raumfahrt der nicht mehr aufzuhalten ist
damit können wir zu einem anderen
Menschheitstraum zumindest für
Fußballbegeisterte junge Menschen in der
Nationalmannschaft spielen und dann auch
Weltmeister werden in Katar könnte es
für die deutsche Mannschaft mit diesem
Traum ja schon am Sonntag gegen Spanien
wieder vorbei sein zum Finalspiel in der
Vorrunde Heiko klasse
es läuft nicht rund bei der deutschen
Nationalmannschaft und die Nerven liegen
blank gut zu sehen und zu hören heute
bei der offiziellen FIFA Pressekonferenz
an der hätte neben Trainer haben sie
Flick auch noch ein Spieler teilnehmen
müssen wir wollen einfach keinem Spieler
zumuten hier so lange zu fahren das sind
Gehäuse mal insgesamt fast drei Stunden
wo man Autos jetzt wir morgen ganz
wichtiges Spiel für uns das mag ja sein
aber ist das ein Grund seit langem
geltende internationale Regeln zu
beachten der DFB muss jedenfalls nun
eine Geldstrafe bezahlen und wirkt schon
so ein bisschen wie in der Schule Ecke
ist halt so müssen wir akzeptieren wie
so vieles und deswegen geht aber
trotzdem der Blick auf das Spiel morgen
die Nervosität ist verständlich denn das
morgige Spiel ist das bislang wichtigste
für Hansi Flick als Bundestrainer
es ist ein Finale das erste finale für
uns in dieser in dieser WM und wir haben
einen Plan wir hoffen natürlich dass der
Morgen aufgeht auf jeden Fall sind alle
fit alle machen mit beim
Abschlusstraining auch Leroy sané ist
nach überstandenen Knieproblemen wieder
eine Option für den Bundestrainer der
tatsächlich die Qual der Wahl hat denn
seine erste Elf muss diesmal nun
wirklich funktionieren ist das schöne
ist ja daran dass man mehrere Positionen
ist auch ein bisschen offen hat das
zeigt natürlich auch eine gewisse
Qualität die wir haben und deswegen äh
lasse ich da schlafen immer schön eine
Nacht drüber morgen früh glaube ich bin
ich dann ein bisschen schlauer nach
einer Nacht ohne solche Albträume
bestenfalls aber auch so wird Hansi
Flick die Abwehr umbauen vielleicht
sogar bringt er ja User Kimmich als
rechten außen Verteidiger und in der
Offensive möglicherweise einen reinen
bayernblock aber entscheidender als wer
ist ja sowieso wie die deutsche
Mannschaft morgen Auftritt darum geht's
letztendlich mit Mut mit Glaube an
unsere Qualität dieses Spiel gegen
spannend anzugehen und morgen dann ist
alles möglich von Reifeprüfung bis raus
aus dem Turnier
und jetzt zu den WM spielen von heute da
gab es diese Ergebnisse Polen
Saudi-Arabien 2:0 Tunesien Australien
0:1 Frankreich Dänemark 2:1 und damit
ist Frankreich im Achtelfinale und
Argentinien Mexiko 2:0
zum Wintersport Francesco Friedrich ist
mit einem Sieg in den Bob Winter
gestartet im Zweier Bob beim Weltcup im
kanadischen Wissler Skilanglauf
Olympiasiegerin Katharina Hennig wurde
über 10 km im klassischen Stil beim
Weltcup im finnischen Ruka III hinter
den Schwedinnen an der Sonne und
Karlsson und ebenfalls in Ruka in der
Kombination kam Julian Schmidt auf Rang
2 Sieger wurde hier der Norwegian Magnus
Riva
zwei oscar-prämierte Filmhits haben sie
in den 80ern bekannt gemacht nun ist die
US-Sängerin Ireen Cara im Alter von 63
Jahren gestorben
[Musik]
nach Fame aus dem gleichnamigen Film
folgte 1983 der kultsong war er Feeling
zu dem Millionen in Flashdance Jennifers
beim Tanzen zusammen
[Musik]
die Lottozahlen dieses samstags sie
lauten wie immer ohne Gewähr 11 24 31 32
34 58 Superzahl 2 weitere Gewinnzahlen
finden sie auf lotto.zdf.de und im ZDF
Text auf Seite 556
noch die Wetteraussichten morgen gibt es
im Südosten in höheren Lagen gute
Chancen auf Sonne in den Tälern bleibt
es auf trüb im Nordwesten regnet es
etwas die Temperatur erreicht zwei bis
zehn Grad in den nächsten Tagen zeigt
sich die Sonne nur selten es regnet aber
auch nicht viel und am Mittwoch werden
nur noch zwei bis acht Grad erreicht mit
niedrigeren Werten im Osten
das war es von uns an diesem Samstag
Ihnen noch einen schönen Abend und dann
bis morgen in der Halbzeitpause auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]